so I'm going to accept one final random
challenge
and
and okay playing Grandma's donation
almost a grand master donation
good luck
staff or Gambit time
oh ponziani time okay
here we go
a very effective opening
especially at the Sub 2000 level
degench is happy it's against always
asking for panziani
this is one of the main positions
Knight E7 is the most played move
and then I'll take the pawn
and this position black has to be a
little bit careful
black is not so careful
it's funny uh Gotham just released a
video I think within the last few hours
covering the panziani in this position
you play bish op B5 check this is one of
the traps he features in the video
I also have a video on YouTube
I think it's one of my most viewed
videos
this panziani trap
and D6 is uh it's a losing move because
of Bishop E5
and very soon we'll see why
I guess we're seeing why
after it takes takes it's a triple Fork
if black doesn't take the knights yeah
there's issues with the queen and the
King
I'm allergic to how bad Black's position
is so I guess thank you Levy for
reminding me of such a nice trap
maybe I'll I'll have to post this as a
standalone YouTube video
make more people aware of such a trap
so there's a choice which thing to take
it's better to take the knights
took the Rook then the queen would take
back
and The Rook is still attacked
the traps will still continue
oh no my Bishop
Bishop was slightly poisonous because
rookie won
I could play rookie one immediately
I'll play rookie one
so setting up some really nasty
discovery type pin
Bishop E6 looks natural but that walks
into this move
the pain continues for black
Bishop G5
actually Bishop G5 just hangs a bishop
what am I thinking I was thinking about
deflecting the queen but the bishop
still defends D6
all right let's play this move
just centralizing
maybe there is a better option there
um
Queen C4 I guess
oh no
my queen
oops
someone con ambulance
oh no
okay no one calling ambulance
false alarm
why do I play Queen C4 I have to move
again
oh what's I do
well let's move here
it was worth a shot
I should probably develop the rest of my
pieces
being up material it's only good if your
pieces can exert their dominance
or maybe I'll trade
and take the bishop first
ah let's take the bishop the other
Bishop first
and then check so if Queen goes to C7 I
take and then when the bishop for free
I know it's a common principle like when
you're up material you should trade
pieces
but sometimes when
the opponent's king is less safe you
should avoid the trades
than just with more material like this
okay up a night in Bishop
play 93.
9 wants to eventually come in
maybe I could have taken the pawn
Knight C4
oh
this couldn't end in a
a fancy way
so the squares around the king are
almost completely controlled Just To See
Five Square
play B4
and okay I'm completing development
there's a B2
developing the final piece
GG okay
that was a fun game you have to dedicate
that game to Levy
C4 Mist Fork yeah I had a fork but
um I saw the mating that I wanted to
control these squares and
eventually set this up
so I'm actually curious let's do a
little bit of data analysis
this trap has been
has never occurred in Master Level play
but on leech us
yeah almost 68 000 games
D6 is still the most played move
I wanted to check the YouTube video
so it's my third most popular video on
YouTube you can kind of see from the
thumbnail
and that's interesting so two years ago
when I made this video
it was only 3 500 players falling for
the Trap
I wonder if I show the
I just want to go forward to the point
where I show the track players too here
we go E6 it's uh wow
yeah about 3 300.
well good job to all the people who have
gotten this trap
anyway
um yeah maybe I'll I'll have to make
this as a follow-up video to this one
oh also don't forget to give a thumbs up